oh how I do hate it when you sing the
devil do that one more time for me no
because there's a very special sound
that you get when you thank you hidden
somewhere in the darkness I get you but
even so just it's a key you had an old a
whole new dimension to the word
country-music that's a whole different
country they don't you wish you had done
it that way you wish then you throw it
my friend you blew it oh there are times
when I wish I could go back and redo the
Konan wait you know you have achieved a
certain status in this world we call
showbiz that I think it's pretty rare
actually you are now if you go to a
Vegas show where there are impersonators
and people know these shows the
impression shows and they do all the big
foots the legend shows they do all the
big stars and I've seen what they do you
now on these shows well well they do
Kenny Rogers and a guy who comes out and
you've reached have you ever seen one of
these well I did more than that I was
doing a radio show in Los Angeles called
mark and Brian and these guys are nuts
just like talk radio and they were
telling me that they had gone to this
show in Las Vegas and I was living in
Las Vegas at the time they said this guy
comes out and sings my stuff said he's
not a good singer but he looks so much
like me it's scary so I said you know
what I'm gonna run over there one night
and see this so I went over and instead
of going on watching it I went backstage
and I took his place and I went out on
stage and sang as an impersonator and
it's the funniest thing in the world to
watch people because when you come out
it's like yeah but you know they're
expecting me to look like the guy to
look like me and to sound like me so I
do the whole thing and I go out after
the show and I'm signing my name and
this guy comes up to me so I'll tell you
one thing you're a hell of a lot better
than the real guy
[Laughter]
so how do you take that I don't know it
was kind of a compliment I think huh
left-handed but a compliment nonetheless
alright now let's talk about your true
passion in life now Kenny Rogers
roasters
we have to talk about this this is first
of all you know there's a Seinfeld
episode that centered around your your
restaurant and this has now become an
international concern is that right
you've got roaster restaurants in other
countries weird twenty four in countries
we have three stores in Beijing China
we're in the Malaysia were in Japan
we're in Israel where I just came back
from Greece the other day and we it's
funny to me it's always fun to walk into
these stores and unannounced I don't
tell usually I don't tell them I'm
coming because I'm checking for
cleanliness of the of the place and the
few do this yourself it's fun you just
check in you like going to the bathroom
and jiggle the handle and stuff we gotta
fix that thing there's a better use of
your time
that's it was it my contract what can I
say you know I sing well I don't
negotiate well we went to Greece and we
went in this place and and the owner
yeah and I have pictures like these
they're all over the wall of me in this
place and the guy seemed looking the
pictures looking at me and look at the
pictures he's like looking for anything
that he can tell for sure that it's me
and it's just funny to watch these
employee and little Japanese people are
walking oh yeah I know it's you do you
have to give to sing them the gambler to
know that the owner is funny because
that's what I do is I tell them I'm you
and I go around and sing the gambler my
way and then I get free food it would
have food because it works like a charm
doesn't it yeah where they would be fool
yes it looks like him but it's perfect
the sonic quality I wasn't sure where he
thought he he had a foolproof way to
find out whether it was me he was going
to wait to see if I offered to pay for
it and I saw it coming cuz he's kind of
standing there like I'm not gonna tell
you and I said well how much is this he
says oh you're gonna pay I said well
yeah why shouldn't that and I never told
him until I started to leave that it was
me and he was dying you okay when you go
to a Kenny Rogers Roasters you have to
pay really you could just go in there
and say give me all the chicken you have
and then do a dance for me that's what
you could do
[Applause]
these people your Kenny Rogers you see
that you could build a statue of me
using the available chicken here I mean
that's the kind of power that you have
but we now realize that you're like a
fool I go in and pay for my I don't know
what you're doing you're in there making
sure the place is clean and then paying
for your food this is not what I did
when I have jobs for denson when I have
O'Brien's potato Hut I tell you I'm
gonna be real real bastard when I go in
there you will do as I have no customers
should see this this I can see this
Conan mashed potato oh man it's gonna be
great I can't wait til I get my own
kisser you fed because I think one time
I was on here I brought some of the food
over here and I think you commented on
how much you liked the food didn't you
comment on how much you liked it do I
get paid for this
not now you might have earlier but maybe
later I'll get something there's nothing
finer than Kenny Rogers Roasters chicken
it is good chicken you know what you do
that's cool you actually you get him on
the sides don't you yeah we have this is
sneaky yeah we've got the best side
that's what it's all about right when we
went into this we hired one of the 44
master chefs in the world to come in and
create the side dishes you know and we
have some of the most wonderful side
dishes if you if you've ever been in
that we have I couldn't even begin to
tell you we have a new in it you don't
know them do you I was amazing I mean I
can't even begin to go into them
there's a wait wait wait there's baked
beans
I remember that of course there are
baked beans can't be sure there are also
napkins available plastic salt is
available in pockets or shakers I'm not
buying any of this you think we're not
first class all right well I want to do
a test here okay sure I actually you
brag a lot about your chicken but I
thought and I swear to god this thing's
legit we're gonna test right now to see
if you can pick your chicken out from
other available chicken so Andy would
you do me the favor of blindfolding wait
wait wait not yet we're gonna blindfold
Kenny Rogers please all right and then
I'm going to all right get his pants
that's what we're really about now let's
bring out the chicken let's go I'm
starting to like this all right now
let's set this up right here audience
please don't tell because this is very
important that we see it Liz can you get
a shot of the different chickens that
are available here okay now let's start
off with let's start off with this
chicken right here how is this the place
to start huh
okay now can you feel this all right
yeah I'll rip off a piece with my
fingers don't worry I washed my hands it
was like late yesterday okay okay what
do you think good good all right well
it's from them one of the finest places
available look all right now let's try
this chicken right here please get a
shot there okay okay we go try that
right there
mmm what do you think good good you're
good didn't have the oomph of the first
good really good
all right now Oh try this one right here
there we go rip off a piece for you
right there
you're sure you washed your hand yeah
sure okay can you pick which one what do
you think was it number one number two
or number three number one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
let's I before we go let's try let's try
one other thing right here let's try to
decide open your mouth here okay
how's that look that's a whole new kind
of chicken we've been working on here at
NBC Huckabee what was that the fun
sometimes Kenny in this life the less
you know the better right oh you can
take the blindfold it it's fine
all right well Kenny I'm gonna plug you
now
wow that is blindfolded the album is the
gift you know you know something you
know something no Conan wait a minute
wait a minute you know something you
need to know something there's a line
you can cross with me that baby it you
will not plug me while I'm blind
[Applause]
you know what's you know it's scary I
look forward to coming here I know you
did the album is the gift this is our
last show Lisa and the Family Channel
concert special Kenny Rogers the gift
premieres December 4th at nine nevermind
[Laughter]
it's their fault Kenny Rogers everybody
give him a hand
Michael Noah checks coming up we'll be
right back